SHAILESH SHUKLA: Good
morning, good afternoon,
and good evening, everyone.
Thank you for joining us,
and welcome to What's New
and What's Next for Networking.
I'm Shailesh Shukla, Vice
President and General Manager
for Networking.
WENDY CARTEE: And I'm
Wendy Cartee, Director
of Outbound Product Management.
We had a very busy
year, and we're
so excited to share what
we've been working on.
SHAILESH SHUKLA: We
have a packed session,
and we'll cover our Cloud
networking portfolio, what's
new in networking, network
security, and monitoring.
But first, the
why of networking.
In addition to being a critical
part of the global Cloud
Infrastructure, networking also
drives real business outcomes
for our customers.
As workloads and workforces
become increasingly global
and increasingly
distributed, the network
is at the front and center
of connecting, securing,
and enabling everything,
while delivering
a seamless experience to
all applications, all users,
and all devices.
For example, our
retail customers
tell us that a high-performance
network is directly
tied to superior user
experience, which translates
to faster revenue conversion.
That's a top line.
I don't want to go through
each of these items here,
but what you will
see is our customers
tell us, in all verticals,
across the world,
that networking is a key enabler
for their business outcomes.
Our Cloud Networking vision
is centered on our customers,
and the vision is this--
planet-scale networking for
a smart and connected world.
Google has built a massive
planet-scale network
infrastructure serving
billions of users today.
And we are leveraging
advanced AI, automation,
and programmability to build
a self-driving network that
makes it simple, smart, trusted,
and open, so our customers can
focus on running and
enabling their business.
Our global network
is at your service,
with 27 regions, 82 zones,
146 edge PoPs, thousands
of edge nodes, 16 subsea
cable investments,
connecting more than 200
countries and territories
worldwide.
We are proud to serve
billions of users,
while staying 100% carbon
neutral since 2007.
And we continue
to invest heavily
in our infrastructure,
our network.
And just this year,
we have already
added four new Cloud regions--
Warsaw, Delhi,
Melbourne, and Toronto.
In addition, we have
announced five subsea cables--
Echo, Firmina, Blue,
Raman, and Apricot,
which connect all parts of
the world from Asia, Europe,
Africa, Middle East,
to the Americas.
On top of this massive
global network,
we offer a broad portfolio of
network and security services
that connect, secure,
scale, optimize,
and modernize your network
and your infrastructure.
To do that, we have
this full stack
of networking
services from layer 1
to layer 7, that provide
high-performance networking
for all your workloads
running in VMs,
in containers, or on Bare Metal.
2021 has been an incredibly
exciting year for us.
We added several new
products this year,
including the Google Distributed
Cloud, Cloud IDS Service,
and enhanced our service
networking portfolio,
with Network Connectivity
Center, Private Service
Connect, Network Intelligence
Center enhancements, et cetera.
Wendy will tell you
a lot more about it.
Let's get started.
Wendy, over to you.
WENDY CARTEE: All right.
Thank you, Shailesh.
We have a lot of
exciting announcements,
so let's take a look at
what's new in networking.
I would like to introduce
our Google Distributed Cloud
strategy, which provides a fully
managed, integrated hardware
and software solution that
extends Google Cloud's
infrastructure and services to
edge locations and customers'
data center.
Our Distributed Cloud
solution is enabled by Anthos
through a centralized
control plane,
so customers can build and
run modern applications
anywhere with low-latency
and operational efficiency.
Google Distributed
Cloud is ideal
for local data processing,
low-latency edge
compute workloads, modernizing
on-prem environments,
running sensitive workloads to
meet sovereignty requirements,
and offering private 5G LTE
solutions for enterprise
customers.
It can be deployed at Google
Edge, operator edge, customer
edge, and/or customer
data centers.
We announced Network
Connectivity Center, or NCC,
a few months ago, and it
is now generally available.
NCC provides a simple and
consistent management model
to connect your on-prem
and Cloud networking
needs seamlessly.
With NCC, you can connect
VPNs, partner and dedicated
interconnects, SD-WANs, and
third-party router appliances
in a hub-and-spoke model.
And we've partnered
with SD-WAN leaders
like Cisco, Fortinet, Palo Alto
Networks, Versa, and VMware,
enabling you to
simplify connectivity
from branch to Cloud.
In addition to
network-layer connectivity,
we also offer
service-layer connectivity,
with Private Service
Connect, or PSC.
PSC provides a service-oriented
networking model
by abstracting the underlying
network, such as pairing,
IP address,
configuration, et cetera.
PSC allows you to create
private and secure connections
from your Cloud networks
to producer services,
such as Cloud Storage,
Cloud Bigtable,
or third-party services from
Elastic, MongoDB, or Snowflake.
PSC is now GA in all
regions, and we introduced
three new enhancements.
PSC with Consumer Service
Controls is now in preview.
With HTTPS Service
Controls, PSC allows
customers to have finer grained
control of their own policies,
and support data regionalization
for sovereign clouds.
We added HTTPS internal load
balancer as a PSC target
to help scale services.
For example, you can
configure the load balancer
to log all requests
to Cloud logging,
or choose which services are
available using a URL map.
PSC is integrated
with Service Directory
so you can auto register
available services to make
service consumption
even faster and simpler.
This is so cool that companies
like Bloomberg, Elastic Cloud,
and MongoDB shared why they are
using Private Service Connect.
And we hope you will
also test drive PSC
and let us know how you like it.
Now, moving up
the service stack,
let's talk about GKE
and Anthos networking.
We released a lot
of features in GKE
and Anthos networking
recently, and we are only
going to cover four today.
First, GKE gateway controller
is Google Cloud's implementation
of the Kubernetes
Gateway API, and it
manages internal
and external HTTPS,
load-balancing for a GKE cluster
or a fleet of GKE clusters.
It is currently in preview
and will GA this quarter.
Second, Cloud DNS for GKE
supports the full Kubernetes
DNS specification, and
it will GA this quarter.
It provides pod and
service-level resolution,
with a fully managed DNS
that does not require
a cluster-hosted DNS provider.
So it removes the overhead of
managing cluster-hosted DNS.
For Bare Metal fans out there,
a BGP-based load balancer
for Anthos Bare Metal
is now in preview,
supporting N-way
active-active redundancy
for faster failover and
efficient utilization
of bandwidth.
And lastly, with
the increasing use
of container network
functions for CNFs,
we are introducing
multi-NIC pods
on Anthos Bare
Metal, which allows
pods to attach to multiple
network interfaces for use
cases such as data and
control planes operations,
multi-tenancy, management
functions, et cetera.
Now, we covered edge,
hybrid connectivity,
service-layer networking,
GKE, Anthos networking.
What's next?
We're going to talk about
Application Delivery.
Our Application
Delivery portfolio
offers layer-7 load balancing
and layer-4 network load
balancing.
In the layer-7 load
balancing family,
we are introducing regional
external load balancer,
which supports
distribution of HTTP
and HTTPS traffic to backends
hosted on Compute Engine
and GKE.
Our layer-7 load
balancers are now
converged on Envoy, a
CNCF open-source project,
as the common data plane.
Leveraging Envoy Proxy, the
regional external load balancer
provides advanced traffic
management capabilities
such as routing and
traffic policies,
so you can steer traffic
where you want it.
In addition, we added support
for hybrid load balancing.
Hybrid load balancing supports
workloads running on-prem
in Google Cloud
or in other clouds
to help customers with
migration, performance
optimization, and
high availability.
You can use external
or internal HTTPS load
balancing, in addition
to TCP SSL proxy.
Together, they're not only
load-balance endpoints
on GCP, on-prem,
or other clouds,
they can extend Cloud
Armor to provide
DDoS protection
to your services,
and leverage Cloud CDN for
low-latency performance.
Next, let's take a quick
look at DNS enhancements.
Now today, thousands of
customers use our Cloud DNS.
And we've added a
lot of enhancements.
One to highlight is
Cloud DNS Policy Manager,
which is in preview.
It enables you to steer
private and internet traffic
using dynamic responses
from Cloud DNS.
Policies may be set up
using weighted round robin
and/or geolocation
rules, and includes
health checks, which can be
used for automatic failovers.
You can use this
to manage traffic
in a multi-vendor
environment, direct traffic,
and set up failover
traffic patterns.
Let's take a look at what's
new in network security.
We announced many new security
enhancements this year,
such as hierarchical firewall,
Cloud Armor rate limiting,
and Cloud IDS.
We are excited to announce
the preview of Cloud Armor
bot and fraud management, which
leverages reCAPTCHA Enterprise
to detect and stop
unwanted bot activity
at the edge of the network.
This integrated DDoS, WAF,
and bot detection solution
uses signals collected
in the browser,
plus threat data to automate
the detection of fraud.
While customers can use these
products together already,
we are simplifying
the deployment process
and providing a more
integrated experience
so customers can accelerate
their time to value.
For more information,
please attend the session
on DDoS, WAF, firewalls, and
network-based threat detection.
Next, we announced
Cloud IDS in July
with our partner
Palo Alto Networks.
Cloud IDS provides a fully
managed network threat
detection service, with
high levels of security
efficacy and low noise.
We worked closely with
Palo Alto Networks
to embed their industry leading
threat detection technologies,
and deeply integrated them
into our Cloud, beyond having
a uniform usage model across
the UI, APIs, and command line.
This means that customers can
pick from GCP native targets,
including anything from a
VPC to a specific workload,
and even leverage
our flexible tagging
capabilities to identify
what they want to monitor.
We surface the alert information
in the Google Cloud UI, APIs,
and Cloud Logging systems,
plus feed the data
to our Security Command Center,
Chronicle, and third-party SIEM
and SOAR products.
It's quick and easy to deploy,
as it is managed, scaled,
and operated by Google,
with high performance
and availability all built in.
Now, with all the
great products,
what about day-2 apps?
Let's take a look at monitoring.
Our flagship monitoring product,
Network intelligence Center,
has been expanded with
several new modules recently.
Network Topology lets you view
actual flows, traffic pattern
changes, ingress-egress bytes
over VPN and Interconnect
to and from the internet
and GCP managed services.
Support for VPNs and
Interconnect is now in preview,
and support for Google
managed services is now GA.
Global Performance
Dashboard gives you
real-time metrics, such
as latency and packet
loss for the Google
Cloud network,
as well as visibility into the
performance of your projects'
resources.
With connectivity
tests, you can check
the connectivity
between a VM instance
and GCP-managed services,
such as GKE and Cloud SQL,
and troubleshoot
issues at any time.
Well, I hope you
enjoyed the What's
New in Networking session.
To learn more,
please take the time
to view the deeper dive
sessions on these topics,
and visit our website
for more information.
Thank you for joining us.